[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Jim is
with us in Nashville hey Jim welcome to
the Ramsey show how can we help
hey Dave glad to talk to you you too man
enjoy your show thank you all right
um I am calling in response to a video I
saw recently that you claimed infinite
banking concept was a scam and actually
got quite pissed off about it so um I um
do not agree with that in certain points
that you made in that um video and I
have set up a policy for my son when he
was one years old he's five now I'm
sorry um
say that again I said I'm sorry
yeah so am I sometimes no
uh so uh so I set that policy up for was
one years old
um it has a 500 000 face value we pay 5
373 a year for 13 years and it's paid up
at that point
um there's a few points that I wanted to
discuss that I just didn't agree with
um do you want to just kind of take one
thing at a time that's fine sure okay
um one of the main things was that you
claimed that the cash value dies with
you and you only get
um to face value uh paid out that's true
that is well it's not true if you
reinvest the dividends back into the
policy dividend reinvestment is not cash
value
dividend reinvestment is because you
have a mutual company and the
policyholders are the owners of the
company and so the profits from the
company come to the policyholder and
they use that to buy paid up additions
that is not the same as keeping your
cash value that's buying extra insurance
with your overpayment
but it still works out to be no
um having a cash value much greater than
the 69
849 we put into it but the actual cash
value not the paid up additions the
actual cash value dies with you
no because yes it does okay but but your
your death benefit is larger than your
cash value so it so whoever you're so
for me I looked at it because you bought
General Insurance
you don't want a paid up addition as a
paid up addition is buying additional
insurance
that's why you're getting more at death
not because you got your cash value but
because you used your policy dividends
to buy additional insurance right but
that's different than getting your cash
value if you if you took those policy
dividends and went and bought a term
insurance policy for a hundred thousand
well you'd get a hundred thousand but
that's not your cash value
well I have a Term Policy no way but you
missed my point okay let you're talking
about you use the policy dividends you
use the money they send to you because
you're in a mutual company to buy
additional Insurance yes creative
editions yeah yeah if you buy a term
policy on the side for a hundred
thousand dollars instead with that same
money you would get a hundred thousand
dollars more than your face value but
that's not your cash value that's
additional Insurance they're different
but in right they are different in term
you can't you don't have cash value to
borrow again I'm aware of that but your
point was that you don't lose the cash
value and my point is 100 of the time by
definition you lose the cash value okay
but okay so as I said Tit for Tat if he
lives to be 80 I'm looking at the uh the
um
read out here if you say he only lives
to be 80. okay all right the cash value
will be worth about two million dollars
but the payout for the death benefit
will be 2.6 million so okay technically
so you take the cash you take you're
taking your bent your policy dividends
and go buy term insurance with it and
you would have more than you're talking
about because you get a better buy on
the insurance than you're getting with
this ripoff whole life crap yes you
would get a high but you wouldn't be
able to use it throughout your life as a
as your own bank I think that's okay but
here's the thing the big thing that's a
side issue that's a side issue but your
first issue was you know he's going to
have all this money at retirement well
let's just do a little present value
calculation on what you put in for a
baby five thousand dollars a year for 13
years do you know what that would be in
a mutual fund
instead of putting it into this rip-off
thing and making four percent on your
money and when he dies he loses his cash
value if you put this in a good mutual
fund you'd have a hundred X 10x the
amount of money and that's your infinite
freaking bank but I we're only putting
in 70 000 and he's going to be that's
how present value formula Works in
finance you know
um look let me just okay take the same I
mean I I understand that's intellectual
let's intellectually deal with this for
a second okay take the same amount of
money when you get off the air and put
it in a financial calculator at 11
percent
and pretend it was invested in mutual
funds and see what it is when he's 88
years old it'll be more a whole lot more
but and he'll have that too with this to
me is a way to no he doesn't have to be
able to to borrow against that's what
you that's called opportunity cost on
your money you put it into something
that's going to make him at 88 have two
and a half million and he should have
had 25 million because you screwed up
and put it in the wrong thing well we
when we screwed up and put it in real
estate too and he's going to get real
estate but then put the money in real
estate but don't put it in this crap
I have to respectfully disagree on what
basis he's getting more money if you put
it somewhere else
but he's able to borrow against this
if you've got 25 million in mutual funds
you can borrow against it but he's he's
gonna have to wait until he's you know
to get that amount of money okay so
you're going to teach him that the way
he becomes wealthy is borrowing against
money that his father invested for him
that's how he builds wealth
said no one rich ever
I mean Banks use this product to no they
do not you've been watching too much
Tick Tock Banks do not use whole life
not ever
thanks nowhere nobody still I would
respectfully disagree no they don't
they do not use whole life life
insurance what bank well
I mean we we could Google it and see
what typically Banks do with their money
but um I I believe typically Banks never
put money let me tell you what banks do
they put it in bonds they're required to
they wouldn't be allowed by federal
regulations to put it into life
it's not a place to invest money because
it's a horrible investment the rate of
return sucks and when you die you lose
your cash value I know but says but you
also
you don't
you're making it sound like I'm losing
money on the whole you are you're
leaving money on the table you're making
it sound like when not me but my son
when he dies yeah that he's only going
to be able to get his he's going to have
22 million dollars less than he should
have if you had put this in a good
investment
you had mentioned that the cash value
guys and you only get the face value
that's not true that is true that's not
I just I just covered that with you for
the last 10 minutes paid up additions
are the only way that cash value
increases unless you're using a
Universal Life program B where you pay
extra to get the extra insurance which
is another form of paid up additions
that isn't coming out of my pocket
though I put 70. it is coming out of
your pocket it's coming out of the
policies pocket I know the policy you
put the money in dude and then it paid
you a dividend and you chose to buy more
of this crap with the dividend and
you're calling that I kept my cash value
no you didn't you bought more insurance
well I know that I put in 70 000 and at
a certain age it's going to be at age
when he's 15 years old that's going to
be paid up yeah Jim and you understand
what paid up is you understand if you're
alive that there's a probability of your
death and so 100 of the time that a life
insurance program is paid up it means
that you prepaid it that's all it means
because as long as there's a probability
of death there's a cost so the insurance
company has always got a cost as long as
you're alive so there is no such thing
as a paid up that's a that's an industry
term that gets suckers like you that's
what it is now paid up means prepaid you
paid all of the premiums in 13 years for
his whole freaking life in advance
that's why it's paid up that hey man I
think you ought to keep it it's perfect
for you but thanks for the call